[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología y en medio de la
emergencia que vivimos a causa de la
pandemia de kobe 19 nos adaptamos desde
nuestros hogares para llevarles toda la
información -soy valentina torres
sánchez gracias por acompañarme la
semana pasada hablamos de la polémica
alrededor de la vacuna rusa contra el
kobe 19 hoy empezamos esta crónica con
la candidata a vacuna que registró china
en la oficina estatal de propiedad
intelectual el fármaco aún se encuentra
en fase 3 de pruebas y fue desarrollado
por el instituto científico militar y la
farmacéutica cansino biologics la
sustancia empezó a ser suministrada a
integrantes del ejército chino en junio
y de acuerdo con los resultados de la
segunda fase induce la respuesta inmune
deseada la patente registrada indica que
ha mostrado una buena respuesta
inmunológica en ratones y roedores y
puede inducir al cuerpo a producir una
fuerte respuesta inmune tanto a nivel
celular como un moral en poco tiempo
esta vacuna que ha sido aprobada en 508
personas usa un virus debilitado
común por lo que los expertos aseguran
que aún es temprano para confirmar que
protegería eficazmente contra el coi 19
la fase 3 de pruebas que se realiza en
el extranjero es clave para determinar
su seguridad y eficacia
cambiamos de continente y llegamos a
américa puntualmente a eeuu porque las
empresas fabrican robots cocineros y
meseros están experimentando un boom
desde que comenzó la pandemia la
necesidad de ofrecer comida al público
sin que haya contacto entre humanos ha
disparado la demanda de estas máquinas
en sillicon valley donde se encuentran
muchas de estas empresas aseguran que la
era de los robots cocineros ya es
inevitable veamos más en el informe de
nuestra corresponsal susana mendoza
preparan cafés pizzas hamburguesas nunca
duerme nunca protestan y nunca piden un
aumento éstos bots cocineros se han
vuelto casi indispensables ahora para
servir comida al público este es el
futuro esta es la única manera de dar
productos más seguros y mejores a los
consumidores mientras generan beneficios
para los operadores es la única manera
de oliver bip in game dirige blend y un
brazo mecánico que sirve batidos
nutricionales en un kiosco y que ha
visto aumentar la demanda desde el
inicio de la pandemia en su string plan
de horas 4 por el interés en blend it se
ha cuadruplicado con el co bit ahora
tenemos contratos múltiples con varios
de los grandes operadores y vamos a
anunciar muchos más sitios en los
próximos meses a lo largo del área de
bahía auto pegaré a gente como max el
robot de ensalada salí de la empresa
chavo tics también experimentado un boom
de ventas en los últimos meses en su
almacén se acumulan docenas de robots
listos para ser repartidos hemos visto
un incremento enorme en la demanda desde
que empezó el coi 19 la razón es que las
barras de comida
tenemos 250 que ya hemos vendido y están
repartidos entre muchos hospitales
universidades y ahora también
supermercados wars no siempre hacen
falta de cara al público
flipy de miso robotics trabaja detrás de
los fogones en espacios muy reducidos lo
que ha generado interés de las cadenas
de comida rápida durante esta crisis
si has estado alguna vez en la parte
trasera de un restaurante de comida
rápida verás que apenas hay espacio
ahora con el distanciamiento social que
emerge mantiene la calidad del producto
es casi imposible hay una gran demanda
de entregas a domicilio de negocios
donde no haya contacto estos empresarios
opinan que la pandemia tan solo ha
acelerado una tendencia que ya era
imparable ahora sin una vacuna segura en
el horizonte los robots cocineros
podrían volverse indispensables
vamos ahora a esta américa latina porque
esta región ha mostrado en numerosas e
ingeniosas iniciativas para enfrentar la
pandemia de kobe 19 en costa rica de
iniciaron las pruebas preclínicas para
comprobar el correcto funcionamiento de
ventiladores diseñados y desarrollados
en el país estamos hablando de un
ventilador de gama media que tiene todos
los dispositivos y alarmas necesarias
que tendrían un ventilador de cuidados
intensivos a diferencia de los de las
otras iniciativas que han salido por
ejemplo aquí mismo en costa rica en el
país que son de clase 1 o clase 2 la
ventaja de tener de poder construirlos
acá en el país es que podemos tenerlos a
la mano y en menor tiempo en un menor
tiempo posible y además el costo como lo
dije éste se disminuye bastante y
finalizamos este espacio en australia
donde un ingenioso ganadero usa un dron
en lugar de humanos para reunir a su
ganado el hombre asegura que el aparato
no le quita el trabajo a nadie porque de
todas formas se necesita una persona que
lópez su intención es reducir
los riesgos para sus trabajadores y
beneficiarse de la tecnología para no
quedarse atrás
boeing si vamos a pensar en metodología
en la industria y en tratar de estar a
la vanguardia tenemos que ver la
tecnología y acogerlo
hemos tenido lesiones en motos antes y
también en caballos previamente por
ahora ha estrellado el drone algunas
veces y todavía no salgo herido así que
creo que hay un argumento para decir que
es más seguro así llegamos al final de
este espacio cuídense si es posible
quédense en casa recuerden que la salud
es lo más importante y continúen con
toda nuestra programación en france 24 y
france24 puntocom
[Música]
estás